>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Music ]
>> Amalia Castaneda:
My favorite part
of being a Junior Fellow I think
is just access to the resource
of the Library, from lectures, to
the people here at the Library,
having the chance to pick the
brains of curators and specialists.
And also sort of mingling
among other fellows
that will also be specialists
in their field one day.
So I think having access to that
network is my favorite part.
>> Jessica Abbazio: My favorite part
of being a Junior Fellow is
all the tours and the events
that we've gotten to participate in.
I really enjoyed the presentations
in the National Library Service
for the Blind because of the impact.
Meeting Dr. Carla Hayden
was probably the highlight
of the entire experience.
>> Justina Moloney: The
opportunity to get to work
with Veterans' Collections
every day,
that's really honestly the dream,
getting to do it 40 hours a week
for ten weeks really
is something brand new.
>> Julia Jimenez: One of
the things I got to find
in the Manuscript Division was
one of the original court document
from the Dred Scott case.
It was in an unprocessed box
in the Montgomery Blair papers.
>> Wister Hitt: The Prints
and Photographs Division had some
absolutely stunning pictures,
photographs, prints.
And the coolest thing
I got to see was going
through all the Supreme Court
portraits, group pictures,
and shots, just as the progression
of time you see the
difference in the Justices.
That was really cool to see a visual
representation of change over time.
>> Irene Lule: The coming here
and seeing the challenges
facing the Library and how I,
as a professional, can go and
help solve those challenges
and contribute solutions
has been great for me.
And so taking that experience and
going back to my home institution
and growing professionally has
been really awesome and just
to challenge myself in a
different area has been great.
>> Justina Jimenez: I think that
this program really allowed me
to expand what I knew, what
I thought that I could do,
and learn new skills along the way.
>> Zachary Sanders: You know,
I've lived in Washington
for three years now and I've
known that the Library existed.
Had my reader's card
for a couple of years
but just never really opened my
eyes to the depth of material
that the library has and the level
of accessibility that there is.
>> Jessica Abbazio: So I would
just advise future Junior Fellows
to take advantage of everything
there is available in D.C. This is
such a rich cultural area
that there's so many things
that you can learn, and do,
and see while you're here.
So absolutely try to do that.
>> Amalia Castaneda: I'll
be motivating more people
from my institution to apply.
>> Justina Moloney: Getting to
work at the Library of Congress
and getting to always carry that
with me that I got to do what I love
with collections that I love here.
[ Music ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.